uh
okay
oh
of my oh
is
um
nice
all right
welcome everyone it's really good to see
all of you
um it is july if you haven't felt that
quiet
yet um it is the month
that i hate the most um
because of the heat but what's great
about july is we as a community
we kind of take a break or we kind of
a downshift as a community
to lean into simplicity and direct
and so what's cool is brett leaves
for a month isn't that great it's
awesome we
finally get a break and we
get to have all these incredible guest
speakers over to
live um and tonight is going to be
especially amazing it's going to be very
very cool
cool um so that's what we do in july
brett's getting a well needed break
he tries to get a break every once in a
while
we're trying to make her arrest more but
so that's really cool that's what's
happening in july what's coming
up soon is summer rama is coming up
on august 5th and 6
so what we need you to do is if you have
been registered for that yet we need you
to do that as soon
as possible because we need to know like
camp
t-shirt size how many puppies we need to
get
um you know all the things that we're
gonna be giving
to your kids at camp um so no
but truly if you want more information
about that you can find brittany
um also let's see one more
thing yeah just because brett is gone we
have
all of our elders here we have a lot of
leaders here that if you need to talk
if you need something uh we are all here
for
you so i'm going to invite us to
pray together before we go into worship
so
uh if you would close your eyes and take
a big deep breath
breath in
and out
another deep breath in
down
and one more in
and out
mysterious christ we
are
humble
to be in your presence
to be in your presence that is with us
at all times
to be amongst your presence in our
community
god to be able to give our breath
back to you and worship as a gift
jesus i ask that you would continue in
every moment during music
during communion during the message that
you would
shape and form our hearts to be
more like yours
but you would give
us eyes to see things that we don't
normally see
ears to hear things that are hard to
hear
but are true
and hearts and souls are
ready to receive the truth that you have
for us
we ask this in your name amen
thank you jesse
i had to laugh a little bit because
we're trying to get maggie break i'm
like i'm not
i scheduled
for those of us who haven't gotten to
meet
each other spend much time together i
just really quickly want
you to know who's up in front of you
because i don't
like this separation between the stages
and the seats out there i really want
this to be
kind of like a communal sing-along
and i think it gets hard when we don't
really know each other
you know we don't know names and faces
all the time
so this is joe this is her husband josh
this is my friend carter and this is my
my twin maggie
i know so
surprised
that
it's my girl shiloh
okay um and i'm mindy so anyways you all
enter in
to this space with us we're so glad that
you're here
and there's room and space for each one
of us in our stories
so let's go ahead and get started josh
is going to leave
this in our first song
[Music]
i believe
you are the way
the truth
the life
i believe
you are the way
the truth
foreign
[Music]
i believe
i
believe you are
the way
the
[Music]
the truth
i believe
[Music]
mercy's
when i'm here
[Music]
it can all come true
i believe you are
the way
the truth
[Music]
i believe you are
the way
[Music]
the truth
the
life
and i believe you are
the way
the truth
the life
[Music]
sing it's to do horizon again
it's a new horizon
line set on you
you meet me here today
mercies that are new
that all my fears and doubts
they can all come too
they can't stay
kids thanks so much
for joining us you guys are dismissed to
your classrooms and
we'll see you after the service
and being with us also in the quiet
and the still
even the somber moments
you are part of it all
and you're calling us
forward you're calling us to be a new
creation
so do you work in our hearts tonight
i lose my ability
to be afraid when i
see the way you
love me
and all the fear that held my
feet to the floor
it don't hold me anymore
when i
see your face
everything changes in the
radiance of your smile
you got this way you're
chasing away those
shadows that hang
[Music]
i'm finding out just who i
am
lose my ability
to be afraid
when i
hear you say my name
it's all the voices that once you
fill my head
they are gone when you speak
i
see
your face
everything changes in the
radiance of your smile
[Music]
hang around
i'm
finding out just who i am
again
i'm finding out just who i
am
[Music]
my fear and goodbye shame
is
[Music]
you have found me on my knees
see our face
everything changes in the
radiance of your smile
[Music]
she got this way up
chasing away those
shadows
[Music]
i'm finding out
just who
i am
lord i fall
down again
i'm finding out just who
i
am
lord i fall down again
i'm finding out just who
i am
[Music]
we're gonna enter into the prayers of
our people
um
and
again if this is your first time just
feel free to
um enter into this with us it's a time
for us to
shoulder each other's burdens to lift
those up before god and believe that
he wants to carry them with us and um
we're gonna read through this prayer out
loud together and then in the
middle of it we'll leave some space for
you to
speak out loud a name or a situation
that's
on your heart and um if you're joining
us online feel free to leave that
request in the comments
and share that with us and we will read
that aloud for all of us to kind of join
in and shoulder that with you and then
we'll finish out the prayer together
it'll be on the screen
jesus for the city of saxi texas and for
every city and community and all of
those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick for the widow
and the orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed
the unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them we pray
to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so now we lift these
names and situations up to you
um
chronic illness
for the
names and moments that we've spoken
about and for those that we've kept
in our hearts we pray to you that they
may
have life and light healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your
presence
amen
how can i respond
to
the love that you have
how can i respond
to the love that you have loved
me
i don't have much
but i have a heart that beats for you i
have a heart that beats for you
[Music]
every part of me
wants to love you like you loved
[Music]
wants to love you like you love
me
my lord
i don't have much
but i have a heart that beats
[Music]
i don't have much
but i have a heart that beats for you
[Music]
i
uh
[Music]
i have a heart
is
[Music]
to you
i
with tonight that's lacking
wherever we feel emptiness
or pain
wherever it is that we have unanswered
prayers
we trust you tonight
foreign
god it's so easy for
the church and christians
to be um
a presence of judgment but god we want
to be a presence of light
we want to be
we want to be you
someone who looked on the outcast and
made room for them
someone who was comfortable in the
fringes
someone who made space
for those that everyone else wanted to
leave
so god give us your eyes give us your
heart
for the world around us
and make us a home for people god
help me to make space for the
uncomfortable
in my own life
we love you god and we trust you to
continue your good work in us
in our own lives in this community in
this city and world
in jesus name i pray
amen
thank you guys so much for worshiping
with us if you want to turn as you sit
and welcome the people around you make
them feel at home
and then we'll get started with our
message
hello hello my name is karen and i have
the honor and joy tonight of introducing
a good friend of mine
um so would you all welcome
dr aaron brown brook up here
[Applause]
come on up yeah so aaron is
a good friend one of my favorite
people in the whole world to marry one
of my other favorite
people in the whole wide world lance
right here
um and gosh i mean just thinking
through how i would introduce you you
guys this guy
does it all he does it all
counselor psychiatrist
tennis pro comic-con fan
loving husband bonus dad
like all the things and
it is such a pleasure that our community
has the chance to listen to aaron
learn from him and so
um he's also going to give
a message that has my most favorite
message title ever so without further
ado
dr aaron brownbrook
uh thank you it's
always great being back here this
community has always
been so supportive of me uh that is how
i met my
husband lance so thank you guys so much
it's just good to be here to give back
what little that i can
um so i've already been threatened to
keep it short
you know my first week
forever we do church for two hours so
they let me know ahead of time this
ain't it uh so we got right into it all
right
romans 12 2 this is from the new living
translation
don't copy the behavior and custom
of this world but let god transform you
to a new person by changing the way you
think
then you will learn to know god's will
for you
which is good and pleasing and perfect
so like karen said i am a
psychiatrist uh that's where i make my
money
i spend most my time learning i've also
spent some time uh that's not actually
with theology and seminary
but uh this sermon particularly talking
about how you think so it's gonna be
coming from my perspective as a
psychiatrist
um so we're gonna talk about how you
change the way you think and i think
this is exactly what jesus had in mind
when he spoke these words
your racist ass amygdalin
so
the title is actually meaningful it
doesn't just make me laugh um but when
we talk about racism it's a very charged
subject
people naturally get very defensive very
upset
but
humor is a defense is actually one of
the most mature defense mechanisms so
let's use humor right off the bat i also
want us to look at racism as a brain
thing not a character thing so i think
one reason we get so upset and so
defensive is because it becomes a
character thing um slightly off subject
i even had a friend of mine asking me
about homophobia and he was like so
would this be homophobic i was like yes
and he was like what if he's connected
to religion i was like yeah and he was
like what my parents think that i was
like yes and your parents probably think
some homophobic things i think your
parents are wonderful
okay so i'm not saying that you're a
terrible person now your whole character
is messed up so we can separate this
from our character and just make it a
mental thing and that way we can address
it fix it without having to say you're
just terrible as a whole
so let's get into it
this
has basically been debunked but if you
listen to any uh podcast for the last 10
years people love to talk about this
feed party brain it shows up all the
time
people like your lizard brain mammal
brain your human brain it doesn't really
work that way but for us as novices it's
still a good model and a way of thinking
about things um so as we evolved over
time our brain basically evolved to do
different things so your most basic
brain the lizard brain it just keeps you
functioning
you breathe you do the things that you
have to do to live it's all about
automated responses so something
happened and i automatically responded
either to defend myself that comes from
that part of the brain
the memo brain is a little bit further
along but not much
we're thinking about memories habits
attachments what you will see is that
each stage what you get is something
where i get to choose my actions more
and more
at the lower stages it's kind of
whatever's built in there fly down at
the higher stages we kind of make our
own decisions and that's the neocortex
that's our prefrontal cortex if you know
someone with dementia it's the
prefrontal cortex that they start to
lose
so they become very impulsive all of a
sudden your grandparent has said
something you never thought they would
have said or done something really wild
it's because they start to lose
prefrontal cortex um but what we're
going to look at is the amygdala which
is a part of the mammogram
so your amygdala actually comes from a
greek word meaning almond because it's
just that little green almond-sized part
of the brain it stores emotional energy
um amygdala is very very pertinent as it
comes to uh ptsd
so emotional memory and like how we
respond naturally based on those things
that's all the amygdala so let's look at
its role in racism
so i'm going to use a lot of studies
um because again
racism comes from the amygdala it's very
automated so i like to look at studies
because that takes us out of our
automated responses this is what i
thought
this is my experience and i may have
experienced the things but that doesn't
mean it's what the whole world
experiences
but studies kind of give us an objective
look at what do we look like as a
society so i think this is a great one
this was done in 2006.
they took
150 white college students from a very
liberal college
and they basically had
two buttons one said pleasant and one
said unpleasant so if you see a
butterfly you hit pleasant if you see
that
something like vomit you're supposed to
hit unpleasant they also had a set of
buttons that were either physical or
mental
but what they did first was they would
show a face
so when you see a face you have to go
through your automatic responses of what
comes up then
and this is what they found out on that
next slide
these largely very liberal college
students had a really hard time
hitting the pleasant button when they
had seen the black face first
so blackface butterfly
i'm still slower to hit the pleasant
button and that's because i have to go
around my amygdala first my amygdala has
these messages that say things like well
black people are more physical
so if i see
blackface
math
my amygdala says hit physical but i'm
like no the word is math come back
and hit mental but we already have these
ideas stored that we have to work around
so what they found out was the people
who were slowest at responding when
black was paired with good had the
greatest amygdala activation when
viewing black faces
so less amygdala reaction means fewer
competing thoughts to prevent someone
from pressing the left button for both
black and good so it was an amygdala
thing
um and this is one reason we struggle
with this conversation
so we'll talk about racism we'll talk
about systemic racism in these things
and people immediately go i'm not racist
i don't think those things and generally
in the neocortex in that part of your
brain you really don't
like you were kind of smart enough
especially as christians like we're
smart enough to put together we believe
in a creator why would a creator say
well i'm going to make these people less
than those people it doesn't make sense
and our neocortex said absolutely that
makes no sense these other parts of our
brain just respond to what's already
there
and so we don't always know what's
happening in these other parts of our
brain
and so we're thinking this is the only
thing that i think and that's just not
the truth because here's what we found
out in the study
of participants showed implicit bias
and this was at the very liberal college
and so
what that tells us is that we just need
to accept that as a part of our
experience as humans
and realistically we know that's true if
you stop now and you think about it this
is what our parents went through
and think about how trauma lasts
think about how trauma is passed on from
generation to generation do we really
think that these ideas and this trauma
has gone away just in one maybe two
generations
we know better
and this is the tip of the iceberg of
the trauma we're not even talking about
things that have happened way before
then and all those things so this is
just part of our experience as humans
here in 2022.
now here's the kind of cool thing
propane law will make you less racist so
blood pressure medicines will make you
less racist
and again that just shows me that we're
looking at a brain thing not a character
thing
i could literally medicate away
someone's racism
is a medication that we use for people
with ptsd
what it does is block some of the
automated your responses that your body
has when it feels anxious if i feel
anxious i'll get shaky and sweaty and
for panel blocks those responses
and now that that anxiety is blocked i
don't act based on what my amygdala
tells me to do
instead i go with my prefrontal cortex
that says well nope this probably isn't
a threat these people probably mean
really well by me and i'm going to act
accordingly so brain thing
not a character thing uh so keep that in
mind as we start getting to the really
hot topics
prepare yourself
moosa
get really calm
um i read this some bible verses to help
you out the amygdala is deceitful above
all things
and it really is i mean it's not
necessarily your heart it's not
necessarily your desires but that part
of your brain it just runs off of these
old functions it can be real deceitful
and when i would do good
the amygdala is on every hand
i need to do well it just doesn't always
come out and you know it's in
relationships like i mean to go home and
be loving and sweet before i know it
like i'm yelling and causing trouble
so we're going to look at what happens
here with uh police officers implicit
bias among police officers this is
something i want us to keep in mind as
we go through because i think it's
really easy in subjects where we feel
uncomfortable uh to just project all of
our stuff onto someone else so it's easy
to just look at police officers because
it's that's nice because if i'm not one
it's those people um but that's why i
love this quote so much
one more time and then we're gonna check
this quote out
okay so i have become convinced that we
do not have a race problem in policing
rather we have a race problem in society
that is reflected in policing
and this is absolutely true
it occurs in the society as a whole
how we police is a function of how our
society already works
let me show you actually how true this
is
so they did uh
a study with denver police officers
um and they also used some community
members basically as a control and so
what they looked at in a study very
similar to the one before
they showed pictures
of white people and black people some
were holding guns some were holding just
like wallets
and basically you have to hit the shoot
or don't shoot button so you have to be
quick to identify
is that a threatening object in their
hand or is it not
so if you oh go back please
so if you look at the one
uh to my left the very first one that
you see
community members were way more prone to
shoot everybody
like everybody just went down so
if we're looking at the police as the
main problem we're doing is wrong this
is a society thing realistically police
officers have been trained to not shoot
way better than we have
we have no problem taking someone out
but what we do see
is that both as it comes to police
officers and in the community
people had a harder time
not shooting
when it was a black person holding an
object that wasn't a gun
so even in instances where they weren't
able to hit the not shoot button
it still took longer to get there i had
to really think it through and get to
the point of saying that's not a
threatening weapon um one other thing
that really stood out to me because this
has become so apparent in all these
facebook and social media battles
um in the very first one again
when you look at officers
you see that they're just like we've
already talked about
they're more prone to shoot at a black
target than a white target
but you also see there that they didn't
shoot at white targets when it was
actually appropriate
so some of what we see in these fights
of like why is one person treated this
way and another person isn't
um
it's absolutely true
it is a part of how our brains are
working
and how we see people that's just an
automated response um take it a little
bit further i'll show you this next
slide
so
figure one to frame 41 and that gun
image just gets a little bit more clear
with each image
and so basically what you're looking at
is if you show a black face first or a
white face first how long does it take
me to figure out that's a gun
and so what you see
basically is that if there is a prime of
a white face it took about
27 slides to get there
um if you look at a prime of a black
face it took about 15.
so we could figure out that was the gun
just much quicker
because i am much more prone to see a
threatening item when i see a black face
and then it also went the opposite
direction
now these are things that your brain
can't help these things have been
programmed in your brain from the time
you were young
to make it clear it's not that you were
born with those things
but by the time that you are three or
four think about how many messages your
kids pick up
by the time they're three or four things
that you haven't even said to your kids
insecurities that you have that you've
tried your best to protect your kids
from and like all of a sudden this
four-year-old has some random insecurity
that you have too and you're just like
what did this come from we pick up
messages very quickly
and some of these messages we pick up
even while we're pre-verbal
so of course we can't come back and
adult as adults and say this is the
message i picked up as a child we don't
even know it
it's just in there that deep and it
comes out without us even knowing it so
how does this play itself out in
policing
um this is a good one for me to look at
because it just statistically shows it
um the risk of harm to black and
hispanic males in particular
is much higher because they're stopped
at a much higher rate
they're also searched at a much higher
rate and i love the fact that this study
was done it was 1.8 million police ops
in california so again we're not even in
texas
we're in california
and it was found that black people were
far more likely to be stopped for
reasonable suspicion
um and were three times more likely than
any other group to be searched
even though
searches of white people were more
likely to turn up contraband
so this is how powerful it is
like my experience even now as an adult
can show me something totally different
and even though my experience as an
adult shows me totally different i still
just kind of act off of these things
these automatic responses that are
coming from my amygdala
let's take another look
so these statistics are actually hard to
collect because not every police station
collects they don't there's not like a
central database where they get sent
into so really trying to find out what
the numbers are it's really really hard
so this is one way they did it they just
looked
at
one area
and they took
what were the amount of times that a
drug a gun was drawn
by white officers in this mostly black
neighborhood versus black officers and
what you just see
is that the incidence of that happening
is way higher with white officers
and that's simply just because of the
idea
of
threat and these ideas of who's
threatening and who's not that we
received very early on and are very hard
to get rid of and even to recognize
to take this a little bit further
i want us to look at this because i
think this also plays into it this is
the cross race effect
so if you have ever said they just all
look alike to me you were correct
don't let anybody get on you for that
they do all look alike
you are much better
at spotting people and telling
individual differences of someone of
your own race and so even when we're
like you have witnesses who are trying
to spot someone else if they're trying
to sign somebody of their own race in a
lineup they're much better at it
if they have people of a different race
in the lineup
it could be any one of those people they
all look alike to me and that's just you
see it so on the left the picture on the
left with the brain all lit up that's
what happens when you're looking at
somebody of your own race your brain
just works better
your brain actually works better now as
far as us for as americans this is why
this is so important
it's reduced by celebrity
it's reduced by background information
however research has also shown
that the neural adaptation that to faces
shows continued racial out group
homogeneity
lots of big words here's the point
if you are a minority group in america
chances are that you've had enough
exposure to white people and growing up
that this effect begins to even out
i've seen enough on tv i see enough in
just all these places may have grown up
in black neighborhood whatever you're
still going to have enough exposure to
white faces where this begins to even
out
but it's not so for white individuals
and that's why this becomes a real
important thing to remember and to
recognize in america
taking this a step further uh that
little yellow loop you see there that's
called your anterior cingulate gyrus
it is the part of your brain that
controls empathy
what we found out oh perfect okay um is
that you have just naturally more
empathy for people of your own race
because that part of your brain will
light up more so you did the study and
basically they just
induced some painful stimuli
and they followed how your brain lit up
and when you saw someone of your own
race in pain
much more reaction i can understand
their pain i can understand how they
feel how they felt
but much less so with other races
so i immediately thought of george floyd
when i read this example because i saw
the
the impact it had on us in society and i
think it's because his pain was so
apparent
like we could look and just see someone
who was suffering and we all empathize
with that and so many people because of
that just really reached out and really
got going for social justice
but in many cases that's just not what
happens
and so with police brutality you also
have to account for how quickly was the
officer how quickly were we as a society
even able to recognize this person was
in pain
and respond to that and so in many cases
we're just not because our interior
cingulate gyrus isn't telling us to
um and so for this one for me just kind
of wrapped it up with how that worked
they just looked at small towns and
normally when we look at police
shootings in large cities
but police shootings of minorities are
actually occur at a much lower rate in
large cities
why because there is exposure to a
diverse group of people
there is more ability for empathy
because i've had more exposure in small
towns police shootings of minorities
happen at a much higher rate than in
larger towns because there is more
exclusion
so just when we put ourselves in a
position to have more empathy these
things naturally come down without
people even thinking about it
all right so i want to get a little bit
into looking at solutions
i'm turning to major league baseball
because i think they've done a great
study with this that was fantastic um
they looked at every pitch i believe
between 2004 2006 it was like 2 000 some
of the pitches
um no 2 million and something pitches
so what they found is that umpires were
much nicer to pictures of their own race
repeatedly um and so basically if you're
a pitcher you want strikes called for
you
and
pitchers i mean umpires of the same race
were prone to give people of the same
race more strike calls uh here's how it
turned out
uh let's go one more
so then while the specific evidence of
racial ethnic match preferences is
disturbing their novel analysis of the
demand for discrimination was also
encouraging to them and here's why
when decisions mattered more
and when evaluators themselves were more
likely to be evaluated by others
their results suggest that these
preferences no longer manifested
themselves
so some stadiums just have camera
systems where we can track every pitch
and so after the game is over i can see
how good the umpire was
miraculously these umpires got way more
even
in those stadiums
during the playoffs when there's large
crowds there's immediate accountability
miraculously
they were just more ready to be fair
and so i do think what we're looking at
and we don't have it right now there is
no kind of centralized system nothing
like that is accountability i think
that's where we have to head because
i think we're still thinking in terms of
character and you'll read the things
people like we're just waiting for god
to change hearts and all those things
that's nice god has already just given
us an ability in and of ourselves to
just hold our society accountable
and accountability works
accountability puts us back in our
prefrontal cortex that goes i don't want
to get in trouble
and out of our amygdala
all right
all right all right so everybody can
calm down these next ones aren't nearly
as bad we're not talking about police
anymore we're good
all right we're going to look at some
health and wealth discrepancies just
real quick
all right so this one's real simple are
emily and greg more employable than
lakeisha and jamal it's a great title um
so they sent
fake
resumes
off and all they did was change the name
and so what they found was that people
with white sounding names were 50 more
likely just get a callback exact same
resume
um
and then with higher quality resumes as
you go up 30 more likely to get
callbacks so simply by the name on the
paper
more likely to get a call back exact
same resume
it's just your amygdala
let's look at this in medicine this one
hurt my heart because i spent so much
time in residency um
2007 they took 220 medical residents and
they just gave them vignettes just on
paper
same type of thing so they're going to
tell you whether the patient what the
race of the patient is
these
residents were less likely to
administer thrombolysis to black
patients than they were to white
patients simply based off a clinical
vignette like it's not like because this
person made me angry i'm just looking at
paper
but they also carried ideas that they
were unaware of like black patients were
more obstinate less cooperative and
things like that ideas they weren't
aware of that came out and how they
treated those patients
so taking this just one step further
the effects
of experiencing racial racism on
cortisol levels
much much higher it's the big blue bar
much much higher from cortisol levels in
your body from experiencing constant
racism
what are the effects of constantly
elevated
cortisol migraines
hostility weight gain arthritis
depression hypertension sleep
deprivation this really hit me
because when i was in medical school
there were so many diseases that we
covered and i felt like at the end of
them there were so many higher
prevalence in middle-aged
african-american males higher prevalence
in middle-aged african-american females
how much of this is just the cortisol
effect on the body
okay uh two more things that we'll just
cover very quickly
so the idea of white fragility i don't
really love it i think it just naturally
sounds offensive it's hard to get past
um so i really want to kind of reframe
it i think the idea of it is basically
this
cognitive dissonance
and that's why it feels fragile
the upper part of my brain is telling me
one thing about myself
the lower part of my brain is producing
something different and our brain hates
when that happens
we want everything to line up together
so when one part is saying one thing and
another part is saying another we feel
very fragile we get very defensive we
don't want to talk about it because i
don't know how to reconcile these two
parts of my brain
so i like the idea of cognitive
dissonance i think it's true
just being like oh yeah white fragility
mostly not healthy
and so then lastly white privilege
so the idea of white privilege for me
and the word privilege is hard because i
think privilege naturally just has an
economic undertone to it we're not
talking about undertone it's just
basically by being a majority population
i'm more prone to experience empathy
just think about how that important that
is i can walk out of my house and be
more prone to experience empathy if i
need to if i need to get health care
when i go to the grocery store
if i need help from the police from a
fire person any of those things
that's the privilege i like to think of
it as implicit righteousness
what is righteousness giving to a person
what they're old as a human
and so these are things i don't think
about so if you tell me i have privilege
i'm like what privilege
that would make sense i see why so many
people go the idea of what privilege
makes no sense because it's totally
implicit
it's just getting what you deserve as a
human it's just easier for you from
being a part of the majority population
that's all it
so very quickly
go ahead and go a little bit forward
we're going to talk about some solutions
you all made it through i'm very proud
of everybody
no one threw a shoe with me thank you i
love you all
okay so how can we be anti-racist that
term is really important because it's
not just
i'm trying to say my prefrontal cortex
but i have to actually actively address
my amygdala it will not address itself
it's going to run wild
amygdala get activated really strongly
it was attachment so like if you have
seen yourself like dating and then all
of a sudden getting close to somebody
and blowing up like why am i all of a
sudden a crazy person i don't know
amygdala and it does not stop on its own
so the first step is really just to
acknowledge it
like i kind of have this crazy thing
inside of me that runs wild whether or
not i even agree so let's all say it
together
i have a racist ass amygdala there we go
my church life is made thank you
knowing is half the battle gi joe
affirms you
accountability
as we've seen before accountability is
huge it makes all the difference in the
world accountability pulls us out of our
amygdala back into our prefrontal cortex
uh three actively strengthen your
prefrontal cortex sleeping more will
make you less racist
like just just think about that playing
new sports instruments reading
meditating all of those things will make
you less racist just because your brain
will work better it'll work at a higher
functioning level
number four associate with people of
other races very important um that
interior cingulate those gyrus that we
talked about before
lights up really well
during like sports and things that
require cooperation so if i'm working
with people of different races to all
achieve the same goal
all of a sudden i'm way more empathetic
we're all in there together
all right
thank you all so much um
are y'all able to see that is that going
to be too small
okay so i would love for us to read our
prayer of confession together
and then we're going to slide right into
our communion communion for us being
especially important with what we just
talked about
taking this time to all just do this
thing together as one community
so if you'll read the prayer of
confession with me
god of compassion and mercy
you sent us your son as the savior of
the world
and told us to love one another as much
as you loved us
yet we struggle to love one another
we have a hard time loving those who are
not like us who disagree with us
or who ask us to face the truth about
ourselves
you told us to love one another
because love is from god
and we often do not love those we think
are dirty hungry
lost or undesirable
it is written that perfect love casts
out fear
and yet we are afraid
afraid for our safety
our wallets and how others perceive us
forgive us god and show us how to love
the way you command us to love
release us from our judgment and our
fear
open our hearts so that they might
receive your perfect love for us
and offer it to the world
and friends the good news is this love
is from god and we are loved by god
in creation god has for
given of god's self
and we are forgiven
all right
so for communion
i'll read the
parts in brown and if you'll read the
parts in red
together with me the table of bread and
wine is now meant to be ready
it is a table of sharing with the poor
of the world
it is a table of communion with the
earth
so come to this table
you who have much faith and you who
would like to have more
you who have been here often and you who
have not been for a while
you who have tried to follow jesus
and you who have failed
come it is christ who invited us to meet
jesus here
you
so
[Music]
c
so
[Music]
you
so
that was um
just a great
reminder um for me anyways of just some
of the work that i still want god to
continue to do in my heart and my mind
and i love the
hopefulness of
separating character
and our brains and the way they work um
so thank you aaron so much
for spending this time with us and for
bringing a message
um unapologetically i appreciate
you so much and i'm glad that your voice
is a part of this community from time to
time
um in light of everything that aaron was
sharing i wanted to close out with the
song we've never done it before but it's
one of my absolute favorite songs
and after
tonight is over i need you to go up and
look
up the original
and listen to it because
you guys
i mean i love
our group here
but
lisa gunger
kills this female part and i cannot do
that
so please go listen to it later um but
if y'all will stand with us i wanted us
to sing this kind of in celebration
of um the world that we want to create
the space that we want to inhabit and
the room that we want to make for god to
bring us to a place where we are all
interacting the way that he designed us
to so
um
yeah josh is going to start us off
[Music]
one more time how about
silent casualties
oh god grant us
peace in these sleepless nights i can
hardly breathe
despite brutality
i know that we'll be free
i know that we will be
free
to let the lighting keep it shining
let it break into the darkness
all the love there is us to see
we'll all be free
in these desperate times love will hold
us here
love will join our heads teach us to
have no
fear
so we lay our hate down
to watch them be
when we see our brother
yes we'll all be free
oh yes we'll all be free
to let the light and keep it shining
let it break into the darkness
all the love dares us to see
will hold me free
let the light in keep it shining
let it break into the darkness
all the love gets us to see
we'll all be free
[Music]
we'll be free
free
we'll all be free
we'll be free
free
we'll all be free
we'll be
free free
we'll all be free
we'll be free
free
we'll all be free
we are free free
we will all be free
we are free free free we will all be
free
we are
free free we'll all be free
free free
we'll all be
free
oh we will all be free
so tell your sister tell your brother
tell your father tell your mother
tell yourself cause everybody will
[Music]
tell the world
me
[Music]
[Applause]
oh man what a
night holy cow catching my breath aaron
thank you man
like
[Applause]
i will say that leaving tonight as the
social media
director for this church i have never
been more excited to post a title
of a sermon on our social media i just
cannot wait to see what
happens it's going to be great i'm going
to have a really good week
um y'all thank you so much for being
here you know
getting to have you in this room those
of you who are joining us
online we are just a beautiful community
that
we get to experience together um if you
need prayer
or just need to talk to somebody we'll
have some
people um also do not forget
to sign up for summer rama um this is
a huge event for our church and a huge
event for our community
so invite your friends even if they
don't go to this church
you want them there if you're
new uh please fill out a visitor card in
the back i
think they're fairly easy to fill out um
only a
few things uh we don't ask for your
social or
anything like that um and on that
note if you will open up your hands as a
sign of receiving as i read this
benediction
for us
you are
a child of god
you
are a child of god
this is
true on your best day and this is
true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved
you are worthy and you are accepted
just as you are and go
filled with god's holy spirit and the
desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
into contact
[Music]
and tell your sister tell your brother
tell your father tell your mother
tell yourself tell everybody
[Music]
uh
foreign
um
you're in better place
children
[Music]
foreign
okay
where are they going right now
um
[Music]
come on
but is
okay
well oh
oh
ah
yes
[Music]
um
okay
hey
and then
[Music]
it's worthy
uh
[Music]
okay
uh
um
[Music]
is
when i'm like
[Music]
you